don't Hulk out Marvel fans Mark Ruffalo
isn't actually being fired from the MCU
but Avengers for directors so Russo
brothers are doing an admirable job
keeping a running gag about Ruffalo's
termination going it all started back in
October when Ruffalo apparently slipped
up and stated out loud the actual title
of Avengers 4 and The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon the Russo brothers
and the bigwigs at Marvel have kept the
title top secret since its reportedly a
spoiler for the preceding film Avengers
infinity war a fire we tell you that the
title of the next Avengers movie is the
whole character took to Twitter
following the taping to send a tweet to
felon asking the late-night host to have
his team edit the episode and save his
hide Jimmy Fallon I trust that you will
cut my spoiler slip on the show tonight
that was off the record homie please
don't get me in trouble with Marvel
barri again DME back AM the supposed
spoiler was ultimately censored and the
black file is placed over Ruffalo's
mouth in the cut that aired on
television but Joe Russo and his co
directing bro Anthony along with Ruffalo
decided to keep the gag alive on line 10
days after Ruffalo's apparent misstep
the Russos uploaded a cryptic photo to
their joints Twitter page celebrating
the end of filming on Avengers 4 Ruffalo
responded to their tweet poking fun at
how unfair it is that they can share
anything they want but he got fired for
dropping Avengers 4 info you fired me
for a measly slip of the title spoiler
alert the Russo brothers and quipped
back you're still fired mark during an
Instagram Q&A session held on Thursday
November 8th at his new bar duello in
Los Angeles Joe Russo was asked how he
deals of spoiler happy actors like
Ruffalo his bartender asks didn't you
fire Mark Ruffalo to which Russo replies
yes we fired him Mark's fired he have to
hand it to them their commitment to the
joke is impressive as for the title that
Ruffalo reportedly let slip on The
Tonight Show one Marvel fan did some
fancy audio editing and revealed that
Ruffalo told felon that Avengers 4 is
titled the last Avenger which would
Neely connect to Captain America the fur
avenger from 2011 but don't get too
excited
someone who was in attendance at The
Tonight Show taping shot down a
speculation stating that the whole thing
was a bit and that Ruffalo told the
audience during a commercial break that
what he said wasn't true don't bother I
was there after they went to commercial
he said none of it actually happens he
said something about Bruce finally
becoming the Hulk again which I hope
will happen in a for having to do with
some lava but yeah it was definitely a
bit
so while Ruffalo and the Russos have
done excellent work whipping Marvel fans
into a frenzy with their title teasing
antics
it looks like we'll all have to wait
just a little longer to learn a true
title of Avengers 4
the studio is reportedly holding off on
revealing it until the end of 2018 as
for the film itself Joe Russo revealed
in his Instagram Q&A that the states
will be way higher in Avengers 4 as
expected and the epic infinity war
follow-up is currently only half edited
with a ton of painstaking effects work
left to complete see the final product
when the still totally entitled Avengers
4 hits theaters May 3rd 2019